[Musique]
qu'est ce que j'ai dans le ciboulot
qu'est ce que j'ai dans le crâne je sais
pas ce que je vais faire ici face à vous
depuis que je suis môme
j'ai passé ma vie avoue fuir au milieu
de vous j'étouffe j'y arrive pas ce
monde j'y arrive pas alors je suis allé
trouver refuge dans les montagnes loin
de tout j'ai pris du recul un peu de
hauteur et là où je suis bien je suis
peinard j'arrive à respirer ce ce monde
ils me dégoûtent une certaine façon nous
dégoûte c'est une société à la con pour
moi parce que le monde dans lequel je
vis c'est un monde qui est simple ou jeu
chaque jour quand je suis là où en
montagne je suis fâché je garde des
vaches
depuis une vingtaine d'années c'est
basique c'est élémentaire c'est
électrique
c'est irrationnel j'arrive pas à vivre
au milieu de vous parce que toi son show
complètement barré je sais pas je sais
pas j'ai pas les codes du coup je
m'éloigne et je m'isole tout seul dans
mon coin
j'ai besoin d'être tout seul dans ma
carapace et je passe mon temps à être là
où je vis entre cinq et sept mois par an
en montagne en ariège c'est pas très
loin d'ici
quand je suis en montagne jura les
jumelles je pourrais presque peut-être
voir le théâtre et ce théâtre i m'attire
même temps il me fait peur et là oh
quand je suis en montagne juillet entre
1500 m d'altitude et 3000 m et 3000 m il
ya 5000 hectares j'ai 400 vaches à
garder il faut que j'en prenne soin pour
qu'elle soit belle j'ai envie qu'elle
soit belle j'ai envie de le
en fait souvent je suis là où je suis je
suis tout seul et je parle dans des
cirques comme dans un amphithéâtre et
normalement il ya personne sauf que là
aujourd'hui 28 cents quand jean quelques
semaines je vais remonter je penserai à
vous je serai là haut est à nouveau y
aura personne c'est une forme de suis
pas vous êtes des fantômes je sais pas
si vous existez souhaite la réalité ou
pas si je suis encore là haut ou pas
chaque année je monte je descends je
monte je descends depuis vingt ans j'ai
adopté ce cycle et ceci que j'ai envie
qui se perpétue gens mais qui dure qui
dure parce que je rends hommage à ceux
qui m'ont précédé aux anciens qui ont
une vie dure rude dans un environnement
sauvage cruel où c'est le physique qui
parle
il faut s'accrocher ça fait mal on se
descharnes tous les jours je marche des
dizaines d'heures je me lève à 4h30 du
matin mais aussi bien j'ai le temps de
flâner de prendre mon temps faire une
sieste manger les fromages sauvage de
baiser avec ma copine si elle vient
tranquille à l'ombre d'un pin il ya des
petits plaisirs quand même dans la vie
qu'il faut pas laisser passer
des plaisirs simples des plaisirs
simples et ce qui me fait peur si je
vous fuit c'est parce que cette société
les plaisirs simples j'ai l'impression
qu'ils disparaissent et en fait je sais
pas pourquoi je suis là mais dans le
fond je le sais j'ai besoin de vous
transmettre cet enthousiasme cette
énergie cette envie de vivre que j'ai
quand je suis là haut quand je caresse
l'herbe quand je caresse les troncs
orgueil quand je sens l'eau fraîche lui
c'est une atmosphère saine une
atmosphère où des enfants peuvent
s'épanouir des adultes ou d une utopie
une utopie que j'ai voulu mettre en
oeuvre moi j'ai toujours la tête
ailleurs je suis ailleurs je rêve de
métaphysique doivent pas d'économie je
rêve pas de mettre en place des systèmes
collaboratifs
moi je vais tout seul peinard de mon
coin mais ce que je veux c'est que vous
chacun d'entre vous vous puissiez vivre
la vie que vous avez amené et que ce
soit dans ce soit de façon saine
là où je vis dans une petite cabane
quand je suis sur la partie haute c'est
le moment où c'est plus le plus fort
pour moi y ait plus aucun arbre et plus
rien on pourrait être au népal on
pourrait être au fin fond de l'argentine
pour être dans des eaux profondes aux
états unis pas un arbre que des étangs
que de l'herbe parfois verte pour faire
parfois jaune à l'automne et les fleurs
de réglisse qui qui qui qui éclot
doucement et quand je marche à perte de
vue tout est rose partout et je sens ce
parfum de réglisse qui flotte dans l'air
et je vois mes vaches qui broutent je
suis bien avec elle et j'ai ma petite
cabane aux six mètres carrés je me lave
dans le ruisseau
je redescends un peu plus bas âge
cueillir les champignons je pêche
il ya un randonneur ou des pêcheurs du
coin qui viennent apporter des bricoles
on discute cinq minutes j'aime bien
cette
c'est éphémère mais le mode de vie que
vous menez est aux antipodes du mien et
moi je suis venu ici
en fait c'est comme une forme de
témoignage on parle des espèces en voie
d'extinction
je suis c'est pas la peine d'aller à
l'eau bout du monde ici à côté de vous
moi ce que je représente en fait je suis
un révélateur de d'une extinction
c'est le monde paysan je vous parle pas
des paysans qui ont un tracteur de 10
mètres de haut avec des charrues de 30
mètres de large
je vous parle des petits paysans qui ont
envie d'avoir une vie simple tranquille
peinard dans leur coin et qui qui milite
pour une vie politique
moi je milite pas pour une pour
l'économie je milite pour une atmosphère
pour pour un souffle pour un pour la
poésie
depuis que je suis môme je cherche à me
dissoudre à me fondre dans le dans le
monde et pour ça pour planer il n'y a
pas besoin d'eux aucune drogue au en
intraveineuse
c'est du jaune au du kof qui co série
que j'ai au plus profond de moi même
là j'entends vos coeurs battre mon coeur
battre et c'est l'univers tout entier
que que j'entends c'est une quête
d'absolu
moi je rêve d'une société qui change de
vision du monde qui qui lâchent prise
sur tous ses espoirs 20 sur toutes les
illusions
j'aimerais que vous
que tous ensemble on s'élève qu'on a un
but commun un rêve commun que quand vous
allez sortir de cette salle vous poser
des questions
vous m'avez pas attendu pour vous
imposer mais de savoir chaque jour
pourquoi vous vous levez pourquoi à
chaque seconde
vous faites pas ce qui est nécessaire
pour aller ce dont vous rêvez moi j'ai
besoin de vous pour continuer à vivre
parce que petit à petit les espaces rey
se restreignent et nous nos modes de vie
en montagne et si vous partiez pas
participé pas un mouvement déjà vous
allez me submerger partout dans les
montagnes pour vous c'est un espace de
loisirs mais pour moi c'est un espace de
travail et c'est une bulle là je vous
adore là mais si je vous vends montagne
je partirai en courant de côté souvent
jumelles avant d'arriver à la cabane et
si je vois du monde je me tire dans une
autre vie au jour est de loin ou s'il
faut dormir sous un arbre ça m'arrive
c'est c'est plus fort que moi j'y arrive
pas mais donc il faut à faut arrêter de
de percevoir ce tout le monde parle de
catastrophisme de le monde qui
s'effondre
certes ça s'effondre mais pourquoi il
s'effondre c'est parce que on sait pas
où on va il n'y a pas n'y a pas de pas
de chemin commun il faut aussi de se
construire un rêve collectif et on va y
aller mais après ça dépend ce que vous
vous voulez là tous je suis arrivé tout
à l'heure j'ai pas de portable et je
veux pas en avoir
sauf que à terme je vais être pieds et
poings liés parce que je ne pourrai plus
agir vous tous vous êtes sur vos
téléphones portables vous envoyez des
messages ceci cela mais tout ça savais
que ça a des conséquences à vous
actions ont un impact sur sur l'ensemble
moi je peux pas je peux pas je peux pas
je peux pas participer à l'est au sens
collectif je reste en retrait du
spectateur j'ai jamais voulu être acteur
et pourtant là je viens je me mets en
danger je suis pas pourquoi je suis là
je suis peinard dans mon coin et là je
viens vous raconter des conneries je
vais je vais revenir dans mon coin
j'ai besoin de vous parce que là haut
quand je suis là aussi un retrait je
vois le monde et dans le fond parfois je
suis un peu cynique je me dis mais
qu'ils se démerdent ils ont foutu le
merdier qu'ils se démerdent ils veulent
ce bordel et qui maintenant il va
falloir s'en sortir les gars moi je me
suis foutu là bas je suis tranquille où
je mets mon petit feu je me fais à
manger moi le monde meilleur pour
s'effondrer
ça ira bien là bas mais ça me fait mal
de voir les légers que les uns les
autres vous il ya une forme d'une
souffrance et le l'ironie du sort c'est
que plus je me suis éloigné la société
est en fait c'est cette société qui 15
qui vient me chercher
depuis deux trois ans ça fait 15 ans que
je vivais en montagne tout seul et puis
depuis deux trois ans c'est comme si la
société me demander de revenir en dix
ans on a un souci
on est parti on est en train de se
planter on se tire une balle dans le
pied si tu pouvais nous donner quelques
petites quelques petites bricoles parce
que le fossé il se creuse et on comprend
plus en fait on sait plus on va la
machine s'est emballée et on est en
train de se perdre
on avance tous salle aveugle il faut
qu'on trouve des repères
alors moi je vous dis juste voilà essayé
de simplifier les choses et m'ont donné
va falloir quand même dire non non au
modèle quand vous propose parce que je
je pense pas que ce soit ce dont vous
rêviez proposer une autre façon de vivre
entré en résistance toute ma vie en fait
en étant isolées du monde c'est un acte
de résistance être simple c'est une
question d'esthétique de passion de vie
ou de mort alors aux armes
[Applaudissements]